distinguished guests
it is an honor for me to be once again a
patron of the world health summit
you might remember when we met one year
ago i told you about the first steps
that we had taken
to increase cooperation inside europe
the world was called off guard by covet
19.
no country was truly prepared
to tackle a health emergency on this
scale
one year ago we didn't even know whether
a safe and effective vaccine
would be available
we had to learn how to scale up vaccine
production
and we had to implement the largest
vaccine program ever
today
more than 75 percent of adults in the
european union are fully vaccinated
we have delivered more than
850 million doses to european citizens
and in parallel
we have shipped more than one billion
doses to the rest of the world
we were the only region to do that
i promise that every second dose
produced in europe
will be exported
and we kept that promise and delivered
to 150 countries so far
so this was european solidarity at its
best
and there's a second success story
thanks to the european digital covet
certificate
travel is possible again
43 countries from four continents locked
into our digital certificate
and 27 more are lining up to join
but we are not out of the woods yet
the year since we last saw each other
has been unbelievable hard
and at the same time it has been very
enlightening and incredibly productive
politicians and the public have
understood that
national solutions alone are not enough
to fight a pandemic
and even more importantly
we have understood
that mutual preparedness is everything
in a global health crisis
the european union drew its lessons and
acted we have created a new health
emergency preparedness and response
authority
in short hera
hera's task is to better prepare for
health emergencies
to detect them promptly
and to respond collectively
its scope
reaches from the collective procurement
of protective equipment for example
medicines and vaccines
to coordinating the rules for testing
and quarantine
hera is ready to launch early next year
now what are the tasks of this new
authority
in normal times
we call this the preparedness phase
in normal times hero will work to assess
health threats
for example to detect them at an early
stage including by innovative methods
for instance today we can predict the
spread of covet 19 in a community by
monitoring the wastewater
so here i will invest in that
in sharing data throughout the new
european health data space
and in assessing new and emerging
biological threats
such as those connected for example to
the melting of permafrost
or the destruction of biodiversity
or take the increasing threat of
anti-microbial resistance
while the world is still focused on
fighting covet 19
this risk is progressing silently
and if our medicines do not work anymore
many lives will be lost
but we need to see even further
bioterrorism
or the unintentional release of
pathogens are real scenarios that
require better preparedness as well
hera will make use of all the available
knowledge and intelligence
and hera's task is to identify threats
early on
to might make sure
that we have the necessary medical
counter measures available
hera will be a watchtower safeguarding
public health
now in crisis times
here i will be given special powers
for instance to coordinate action with
our member states through a health
crisis board
because we need fast and decisive
decision making
or for example to procure medical
equipment medicines vaccines
or even critical raw materials
just to tackle the crisis
hera will support the development of
state-of-the-art diagnostics
that can be readily modified
but also high-end medical devices
such as for example the next generation
of portable ventilators
and hera will work on new flexible
technologies for even better vaccines so
you all know the demand is huge
hera will help to bridge gaps in the
existing european health system and to
take cooperation to a new level
let me give you some examples
it will work on pan-european clinical
trials
it will create a network of european
production sites
for critical medical countermeasures
which then can be activated quickly in
case of emergency
and it will work with private companies
to address the bottlenecks in our supply
chains
in early 2022 we will launch
work on ever-ready industrial production
capacities
so to manufacture vaccines and medicines
rapidly in case of a crisis
and finally i don't need to explain to
you that global cooperation is
vital
cross-border health threats need
cross-border responses
so here as horizon will be wider than
our union
another of hera's core tasks
will be to join forces
with its international counterparts
we have already started to build bridges
to the work of the who
and of barda in the united states
we are in contact with third countries
in our neighborhood
such as the united kingdom switzerlands
and the western balkan countries
our aim is to form a core group
that will lead to a truly global network
of heroes
and more will come with the african cdc
with the future african medicines agency
and of course with other global players
such as seppi garvey and the
philanthropic foundations
beyond such cooperation i am convinced
that we need a global standard for
health preparedness
and this is why i organized together
with the g20 the global health summit in
rome earlier this year
with the rome declaration
the world has endorsed a set of guiding
principles for global preparedness
and preparedness is now at the center of
our union's action
and of course
the importance of this new endeavor
must also be reflected in its resources
therefore i have proposed an
unprecedented 50 billion euro budget
over seven years
for our health preparedness mission
our union
our member states
and of course the private sector
have a role to play and a contribution
to make
europe stands ready to contribute and
invest in pandemic preparedness
at home
and worldwide
ladies and gentlemen
for over 20 years now the world health
summit has been at the spare head of
international cooperation on health
and today finally there is broad
consensus
we must improve our preparedness and our
ability to respond to health crisis
so let's make it happen
i wish all of you
a very fruitful world health summit
thank you very much